[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
connor oh
je peux
faire t'appartient
ne bouge pas laisse moi voir ça ne bouge pas amy
je peux le voir d'
accord prêt
je l'aime c'est super gentil parce que
c'est terrible
[Musique  ]
oh mon dieu où étais-tu joel
amy je t'aime je vais venir te trouver
pendant tout le
temps d'Amy
et maintenant je l'ai enfin trouvée
toi tout seul moi aussi tu n'as pas à en
parler
tu veux venir avec moi
c'est une épée de samouraï ouais oui c'est
écouter ton instinct ici mec et
si j'ai des instincts terribles
[Musique]
tu mourras super  discours encourageant
tu as fait tout ce chemin pour une fille hein
as-tu déjà entendu le terme imbéciles aaron
non  amy tu me manques tu
as perdu ce mur nous pourrions encore reprendre
notre monde
tu es plus un survivant que je ne le pensais
oh c'était génial oh j'ai l'impression que tom
croise avec
toi